[Musik]
nachdem die elf männer ein gebet
gesprochen haben trägt sieht der
helikopter in einen winkel der schweiz
wir wilder kaum sein könnte hinter
tiefen schluchten und steilen abhängen
liegt das innere alle die eine halbinsel
im wallis eismeer
über 1000 schafe sind in diesem weiten
gebiet verstreut
es ist ende sommer und die jungen männer
haben die aufgabe die tiere zu finden
und ihren besitzern zurück zu bringen
drei tage haben sie zeit dazu
[Musik]
das gebiet absuchen
als treiber
das ist kari kummer einer der zwei
säckelmeister so heißen hier die
anführer der scharf treiber der heli hat
ihn mit seiner gruppe zu robust ins
gebiet geflogen hoch über dem
aletschgletscher von hinten nach vorne
durchkämmen sie das gebiet auf der suche
nach schaffen immerhin die
wetterverhältnisse sind freundlich
das große problem
blendend als gewesen dann steigert
doch scharfe finden die meine hier oben
nicht auch nach einer stunde haben sie
noch kein einziges tier gesehen
jesus
war hier kenntnis ist
karies
gewinnabführung der wildnis getriebe und
je ist also wirklich sehr selten dass
sie chancen
einige hundert höhenmeter tiefer steht
daniel schwierig der zweite
säckelmeister der von unten die suche
nach den schafen koordiniert schon bald
trotten die ersten schafe herbei
walliser schwarz nasen es ist dies der
anfang einer gewaltigen schafherde die
bis morgen abend auf über 1000 tiere
anschwellen soll wenn alles gut geht
vom inneren teilung für manager müssten
ihre stadt lieber und das sind rund
45 kilometer vor zentriert
diese person
mittels funk kontakt stehen die männer
in ständiger verbindung von unten kann
da nie die helfer über den felsen auf
tiere aufmerksam machen welche die
scharf treiber von oben nicht sehen
können und immer mehr schafe kommen so
zusammen
in norderstedt dani zur seite mit
adlerkopf von totenschädel leben und tod
das nachbarn wie passend in dieser
ebenso überwältigenden wie
unerbittlichen natur
[Musik]
und dann wird es zum ersten mal richtig
mühsam ein einzelnes scharf das ist
immer ganz schlecht denn tiere außerhalb
der erde geraten schnell in panik können
kaum in die gewünschte richtung
getrieben werden es droht gar ein sprung
über die felswand so fließt der schweiß
von gleich mehreren männern um das
verwirrte scharf auf den richtigen weg
zurückzubringen der verdacht bestätigt
sich das tier ist krank hat eine
entzündete klar deshalb konnte es mit
der herde nicht mehr mithalten
madrid das seien oft zu versuchen etwas
wie das geht wird sehr schwach dass ich
mir sage tiere hat
[Musik]
das innere alle chi ist sehr weiträumig
oft auch unübersichtlich doch da es von
allen seiten durch gletscher und
schluchten begrenzt wird ergibt dies
einen riesigen natürlichen fähig wo die
1000 schafe einen sommer lang ohne die
aufsicht durch hirten beiden nicht mal
bär und wolf haben die abgelegene
halbinsel mit ihren vielen schafen
bislang entdeckt
[Musik]
damit
säckelmeister kari kummer ist hoch über
dem aletschgletscher immer noch auf der
jagd nach den wenigen scharfen diese
hier oben aufhalten 4 hatte entdeckt die
wird er nach unten treiben doch andere
könnten sich hinter felsen verstecken
denn die mittagshitze treibt die schafe
in den schatten
die scharf treiber riskieren kopf und
kragen bei ihrer arbeit
aber
das ist momentan noch das gelände
lassen
zwölf stunden am unwegsamen bergauf und
runter und wieder rauf im prüf und embry
wieder walliser sagt freude am wandern
kommt dabei nicht auf es ist nur
anstrengend verdammt anstrengend
überhaupt wandern ist etwas für
touristen ohne notwendigkeit gehen
dieser männer jedenfalls nicht in die
berge
jetzt suchen wir jetzt ganz gewesen und
da sehe ich links von bach die waren
aber auch die jungs brauchen mehr aktive
bisher über libreka
die schwierige und so moderat wie
steiner sind
zwar die temperaturen relativ errichter
wieder schlacht ist
drei einzelne schafe dies sieht nach
einem mühsamen strapaze aus karussell
fahren nennt ascari hin und her und drum
herum und das in einer abschüssigen
geröllhalde
kari verschwindet irgendwo in der tiefe
auch eine gämse aufgeschreckt durch die
wilde flüche sucht das weite
dafür kommen immer weitere schwarz nasen
aus den steilen hängen herbei diese
traditionellen walliser schafe mit den
hörnern für walliser schafzüchter gibt
es nur diese schafe alle anderen die
harmlosen die weißen alpen schafe und
die braunen werden lediglich muttern
genannt
erst nach längerer zeit taucht kari
wieder auf
aus allen stünden und senken strömen sie
plötzlich herbei
die schafe scheinen zu spüren dass der
sommer vorbei ist
und immer mehr tiere reihen sich ein in
den zug richtung dreas töte
scharf zackig diffus horner die den
trust gletscher flankieren es ist eine
überwältigende natur doch lieblich oder
gar freundlich ist sie nicht und
freiwillig gibt sie nichts her auch die
1000 schafe nicht
dani und zwei kollegen reichte es für
eine kurze mittagspause
tief unten klärt eine alpinisten gruppe
den aletschgletscher
doch schon ist wieder schluss mit der
rast
[Applaus]
zwei schafe wollen nach unten ausbrechen
die männer machen das karussell
doch ein tier lässt sich partout nicht
nach oben treiben
solche aktionen zählen mächtig an den
kräften dabei ist erst mittag an diesem
ersten tag der scharf sagt
doch auch diese hilfe kann das tier
nicht umstimmen erneut heißt es aus es
ist ein einziger ärger
was mich
dani packt das tier trägt es den anderen
schafen hinterher in der hoffnung dass
es in der herde wieder vernünftig wird
schafe sind herdentiere soziale wesen
eine hackordnung benötigen sie nicht
allein die herde gibt ihnen schutz und
sicherheit
endlich kommt die trieste hütte in sicht
das ziel dieses tages
doch zuvor sind noch zwei hindernisse zu
überwinden die beiden bachläufe mit dem
eiswasser des trias gletschers
die schafe zögern stauen sich vor dem
tosenden wasser
die braunen muten sind die mutigsten
wagen zuerst den sprung über den bach
[Applaus]
es braucht den druck von hinten damit
sich auch die restlichen tiere bewegen
und es braucht den helfer im bach drin
der jene schafe aus dem reißenden wasser
fischt die den sprung nicht schaffen
nun ist es noch ein spaziergang zur
hütte hinunter wo die scharf treibe die
nächsten zwei nächte verbringen werden
doch noch ist nicht arbeitsschluss ein
verletztes schaf liegt im gras unfähig
weiterzugehen vier männer laden das tier
auf ihre geisel stücke
das ist wohl zu viel zweckoptimismus
denn dass dieses schaf übermorgen die
lange reise auf die belalp machen kann
ist kaum wahrscheinlich trotzdem
verarztet das tier mit den mitteln die
ihnen hier zur verfügung stehen
mit einem verschnitt mit
einem schock
[Applaus]
immerhin bei der flitzer schuld
wie hoch sind
die indy 500 hälfte
als moderat der
11freunde aus naters sie sind zusammen
aufgewachsen
nur drei von ihnen haben überhaupt
schafe doch bereits die väter und
großväter haben diese arbeit hier oben
getan und so führen sie die tradition
weiter allein wegen der 250 franken die
sie pro tag von der bürgerschaft naters
erhalten würden sie das nicht auf sich
nehmen
nein
philosophierende schafhirten sind das
nicht die sprüche sind eher derb und
vielleicht ist es gut dass einiges was
hier gesprochen wird im schwer
verständlichen walliser dialekt
verborgen bleibt
die wetteraussichten für die kommenden
tage sind nicht ermutigend
[Musik]
ingo sprunger ist halt rockfans cdc der
30-jährige arbeitet bei der
kehrichtverbrennung oberwallis schafe
hat er keine und in die berge zieht es
ihn auch nicht gerade und doch macht er
seit drei jahren mit bei diesem scharf
abtrieb im inneren alle die seine
motivation dazu die antwort klingt bei
allen beteiligten ähnlich
ja das ist letztendlich die
kameradschaft
schwarz und der
rekordmeister sind und das sind zwei von
derwesten kollege und das in erster
linie alleinerzieher gemacht was mit dem
geld macht
des showbiz herzblut und und ja
wohl das
was man kaum glauben kann die wolle
vieler walliser schwarz nasen endet hier
im ofen der kehrichtverbrennung
eigentlich ist es eine schande dem markt
ist dieser traditionelle nachhaltige
rohstoff heute nichts mehr wert
zusammen mit bruno schweri dem koch der
scharf treiber züchtet ingo kampf für
walliser eringer kühe oberhalb von
naters zäunen die beiden ein feld ein in
einigen tagen werden die schwarzen kühe
von der alb zurückkehren und hier eine
saftige herbst beide finden
kari kummer 25 jahre alt ist
lastwagenchauffeur gemeinsam mit den
anderen scharf treibern ist der in
naters aufgewachsen ein bürger und das
hat ihn auch zum amt des ex-meisters
befähigt zusammen mit daniel schwere
wurde er von der bürgerschaft in dieses
ehrenvolle amt gewählt
doch früher politik und
[Musik]
bürgerschaft sind
seit sieben jahren holt kari die schafe
zurück aus dem inneren alle g nächstes
jahr soll es zum letzten mal sein dann
will die ganze freundesgruppe aufhören
dann müssen sich neue hinter die schafe
machen
[Musik]
der andere wege gestanden das machen die
tradition
also
auch kari züchtet keine schafe sondern
ehringer kühe zwar gehören die schwarzen
tiere zu den kleinsten rinderrassen
europas und der nutzwert ist gering
dafür sind die weibchen besonders
aggressiv im frühling lässt man die kühe
im wallis in kämpfen gegeneinander
antreten
vormonat dagegen dass gezielt will nun
mit 16 hotelier politiker prominente
lido fahrzeug mit der jährlichen aufwand
dass der preis die strategie schon
zusammen
[Musik]
doch es gibt ihn den passionierten
schafzüchter unter den schreibern der
25-jährige säckelmeister daniel schweri
besitzt 40 schwarz nasen 16 davon die
jüngeren macht er heute schön für den
großen tag die jährliche scharf
prämierung freunde helfen beim waschen
der tiere im alten schlachthaus von
naters dani ist gelernter metzger heute
arbeitet er bei den bergbahnen doch sein
wahres interesse gilt den schafen
schöne schweiz nasen können liebhaber
preise von über 2000 franken erzielen
gering hingegen ist der schlacht wert
rund 250 franken und fast wertlos ist
die wolle welche die männer so gründlich
schrubben denn der preis für schafwolle
ist ins bodenlose gefallen seit die
schweizer armee auch bei den wolldecken
und uniformen abgerüstet hat
das lohnniveau
und die wohnungs oder gewisses
mindestmaß
das ist ja so
[Musik]
nachdem das fell am nachmittag
getrocknet ist greifen die hände erneut
in die rolle es wird entwirrt und
gezupft es wird nach jedem knötchen im
fell gesucht mit einer hingabe die nur
der wahre schafzüchter verstehen kann
bis nach all den mühen aus der walliser
schwarz nase ein fettes will klein
geworden ist es war schon immer so und
so soll es auch bleiben das ist die
tradition
[Musik]
doch nun 200 jahren noch gewährt
kurz nach fünf uhr morgens es ist der
zweite tag der schatzsuche kari ist bei
den ersten die aufstehen denn er wird
den längsten anmarsch ins suchgebiet
haben
die anderen bösen noch auf den 5
schlafplätzen die den elf männern für
die nacht zur verfügung standen
dann macht sich die gruppe mit kali im
schein der stirnlampen auf den weg nach
ganz oben
das gebiet das sie heute ab suchen
werden ist nicht mehr ganz so groß wie
gestern dafür noch steiler und auch
gefährlicher
etwas später hat dani auf der seite
moräne des ober aletschgletscher seinen
platz eingenommen
von hier aus leitete er kari und seine
männer am abhang gegenüber zu jenen
schaffen die sich in den felswänden
verstecken
kari ist gerade dabei im steilen gelände
drei verirrte tiere auf einen sicheren
weg zurückzuführen es sind
halsbrecherische manöver über
senkrechten abgründen
rolle
ausruhen geht nicht die nächsten zwei
schafe nahe der panik müssen aus der
wand geholt werden
das risiko für zwei ich auf den
gefällt-mir
und kari steigt wieder ab in die
vertikale er der vor fünf wochen sich in
einer schweren operation eine niere
entfernen lassen musste
inzwischen hat die sonne auch die belalp
erreicht wo der schachzug morgen
hingehen soll
von seinem beobachter posten aus hat
dani eine ganze herde über einer
steilwand entdeckt
es sieht nicht gut aus die tiere sind
auf falschem weg
wenig später sind die tiere in eine
sackgasse geraten es gibt kein vorwärts
rückwärts mehr kali und seine leute
müssen zu den tieren absteigen und ihnen
einen ausweg weisen mehrere hundert
meter senkrecht über den spalten des
ober aletschgletscher bewegt sich die
herde talwärts
[Musik]
und so geht es den ganzen morgen weiter
immer neue schafe müssen aus der wand
geführt werden
bis kari endlich mit den letzten tieren
ebenfalls unten auf der seite moderne
ankommt die schinderei hat sich gelohnt
wieder sind einige hundert schafe
zusammengekommen
am rande der ober alex schlucht werden
die tiere vorangetrieben zu einer senke
weiter talwärts wo die gestern
gesammelten schafe walten dann sind
erstmals alle schafe beisammen 1020
sollten es sein
möglicherweise wurden jedoch einige
übersehen vermutlich sind andere zu tode
gekommen durch steinschlag gewitter oder
krankheit dies sind die überreste eines
schafes das im vorjahr verendet ist
die riesige herde wird zu einem
geeigneten platz getrieben wo die tiere
die nacht über bleiben werden bis morgen
früh der rückmarsch beginnen kann es ist
eine hauptprobe die misslingt die schafe
am kopf des zuges sind nicht zu bremsen
und brechen immer wieder aus hinten
hängen die tiere zurück der zug dehnt
sich in die länge das ist ganz schlecht
das war
so
heftig dass und hubert aussterbens
langsam
erschöpft legen sich die männer in die
letzten sonnenstrahlen
am abend ziehen dunkle wolken auf die
vorhersagen erfüllen sich sturmböen
bringen einen wetterumschwung die
temperaturen fallen markant und in der
dritte auf 2200 metern über meer ist man
blitz und donner plötzlich
furchterregend nah
[Musik]
mittlerweile sind die eheringe kühe von
ingo und bruno von der alb gestiegen und
auf ihre herbst weiter angekommen es
sind anspruchslose anpassungsfähige
tiere die aus alten zeiten stammen
bereits mit den römern sollen sie ins
wallis gelangt sein
gleich hinter der weiter der eringer
kühe widme sich martin schnidrig tieren
die ebenfalls selten und besonders sind
und fast nur noch im wallis vorkommen
schweiz hals ziegen martin hilft jeweils
beim schaf abtrieb mit doch selbst
züchtet er diese ziegen das gibt viel
arbeit aber kaum einen ökonomischen
nutzen martin macht das der schönheit
der tiere wegen und weil der vater es
schon gemacht hat schwarzer als ziegen
eringer kühe schwarz nasen schafe die
walliser haben ein großes herz für
seltene tiere die zwar kein geschäft
versprechen aber außergewöhnlich
aussehen sofern diese tiere nicht mehr
oder wolf heißen
und dann kommt der große tag der schwarz
nasen züchter von bäumen und umgebung
zusammen mit freunden treibt dani seine
herausgeputzten schafe zur jährlichen
prämien
ein stelldichein der schafzüchter
einfache leute sbb angestellte postler
fabrikarbeiter viele pensioniert
hobbyzüchter viel geld lässt sich mit
den schwarzen nasen nicht machen
immerhin gibt es jährlich rund 100
franken pro tier an subventionen
doch wertvoller ist das heutige urteil
der juroren
[Musik]
beim mega stoff storkow magic traummaße
oder ausgesucht einige meter
so hell wie sie
die schwarz nase ist eine alte primitive
schafrasse genügsamen gut ans
hochgebirge angepasst unter den 400
30.000 schweizer schaffen sind die
waliser schwarz nasen eine
verschwindende minderheit
ökonomisch von geringem interesse eher
armen fleisch doch hartnäckig gehegt von
männern die ganz unzeitgemäß schönheit
über das geschäft stellen
die show szene die so gepflegt finden so
schön ist kein waschpulver
der frauen darin nicht als echte chance
gibt
die sachverständigen haben ihres amtes
gewaltet die resultate stehen fest und
sind so darf man sagen fast durchwegs
gut bis sehr gut
also könnte man sich gelassen diesen
friedlichen bild ergeben wäre da nicht
dieser blutige sommer gewesen denn der
wolf geht um und weckt in den walliser
schafzüchtern einen großen groll
[Musik]
121 stück schon vor der wohl größte hat
hans wissen hat diesen sommer im binntal
14 seiner 36 schwarz nasen an den ball
verloren seither schläft er schlecht
der wolf der in einer beschaffung wenn
man geht und die haltung scharf sein
muss erledigt und ein objekt das dass
das
erkennt
und herdenschutzhund würde den übrigen
ernte schutzhunde wenig gesehen ist das
nicht wollte dass bei mir
zwölf wichtige schmecken
[Musik]
es ist der morgen des langen marsches
vom schneefall der nacht liegt noch
matsch vor der hütte
ein glück dass sich der schnee nicht an
den hängen festsetzen konnte der nebel
macht die sache schon mühsam genug die
schafe haben die nacht in einer mulde
verbracht von einem behelfsmäßigen zaun
zusammengehalten
[Applaus]
vor dem start ist eine große anspannung
zu spüren
[Applaus]
[Musik]
dann zieht kari voraus mit einem sack
salz in der hand
[Musik]
gleich zu beginn weg der zug in ein sehr
steiles couloir ein gesteinsbrocken
liegen hier gefährlich locker die
schneemassen 8 hat die scharfe schwere
werden lassen
wir wollen aber die händler
[Musik]
es wird nun klar dass das schaf mit der
entzündeten klaue die reise nicht
mitmachen kann
dani entscheidet das tier zurück zu
lassen
[Applaus]
was frau schwach läuft das magen bis
märz momentan so wehrt sich man müsse
nur zieht anke
das wäre ja zu merkels
[Applaus]
das tier wird später von seinem besitzer
zurück geholt werden mit hilfe eines
helikopters
während das schaf mit dem gebrochenen
beinen diesen alpsommer nicht überlebt
hat
[Musik]
[Applaus]
weber macht
durch eine senkrechte felswand führte
abstieg tief hinunter in die schlucht
des ober aletschgletscher
die ersten schafe es sind die forschen
braunen die mutter sie gehen mit
leichtigkeit über den steg doch die
nachfolgenden tiere stocken
die eigenwilligen walliser schwarz nasen
diese dickschädel weigern sich weiter zu
gehen es taut gefährlich in der steilen
wand die männer müssen hand anlegen eine
weitere kräfte zehrende übung auf dem
langen weg nach hause
[Musik]
[Applaus]
schwindelerregend der blick zurück als
sich der nebel kurz lichtet
nach zwei tagen schinderei und macht
zwei kurzen nächten liegen die nerven
blank
[Musik]
die letzten stunden haben viel kraft
gekostet es leiden die männer und es
leiden die schafe eine rast ist
angebracht
[Applaus]
er musste sich erholen
also
die tag durch sondern auch als im
vormonat unter dem motto kreiert das ist
noch mal zu machen
[Musik]
nein
[Applaus]
[Musik]
auf halbem wege wechseln die männer die
verschmutzten kleider der letzten tage
gegen neue einheitliche hemden und hosen
freunde und verwandte sind in scharf
treibern entgegengekommen und haben
frische kleidung und etwas zu essen
mitgebracht
[Applaus]
[Musik]
vier besonders schöne scharfe werden mit
bunten bändeln sogenannten blumen
geschmückt mensch und hier sollen beim
eintreffen auf der belalp eine gute
gattung machen dann setzt sich der zug
wieder in bewegung
[Applaus]
die 11 freunde sind ein eingespieltes
team es sind nicht viele worte notwendig
jeder weiß wo er gebraucht wird oben und
unten und hinten und vorne schon sieben
sommer besorgen die jungen männer diesen
anspruchsvollen scharf abtrieb doch die
strapazen der letzten tage gehen in die
knochen und abseits vom weg verliert
dann im steilhang den tritt
[Musik]
jetzt erstrahlt
entweder
[Applaus]
du maine gebiet ja die chancen im handel
wird stellt
[Applaus]
und dann nach acht stunden weg der
spektakuläre einstieg ins finale in
ängsten kehren hinauf auf die bilanz
[Musik]
dani parejo und ihre freunde sie sind
heute die helden der welt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die letzten nebelfetzen sind vertrieben
und das unverstellte panorama erlaubt
nochmals einen blick zurück auf die
grandiose bühne auf der dieses stück in
den letzten drei tagen spielte
alles ist gut die schafe sind drin im
feld doch sind es auch tatsächlich
sämtliche
1020 schafe die anfang sommer von ihren
besitzern ins innere alle getrieben
worden sind
[Applaus]
[Musik]
sollte
ausgeschlafen haben vom fahren natürlich
blöd aus dem boden zu schlafen
[Applaus]
die glieder sind schwer müde der kopf
doch ans schlafen denkt jetzt niemand es
ist die nacht der elf verschwitzten
helden schäferfest auf der belalp
[Musik]
die frauen und freundinnen sind
erleichtert dass die männer gesund
zurückgekehrt sind sie ahnen welchen
gefahren sich ihre männer in diesen
tagen jeweils aussetzen
[Musik]
das fest war gestern heute ist der tag
der abrechnung auch der vater von karl
walter kummer ist hier um seine schafe
abzuholen noch ist nicht gewiss ob es
alle sein werden nur eines beruhigt hier
jeden schafhalter bär und wolf haben
bislang noch nicht zur fetten beute im
inneren alle gefunden glücklich wie
jetzt herrsche und geblieben ist
besetzung saubere hände erfrieren
das war meine rolle ist in der bronx
gilbert
gress
[Musik]
der zigaretten
im internet weniger die vorlage
[Musik]
wird ist das nicht möglich
auch die 11 freunde sind nach einer
kurzen nacht zum ort der wahrheit
gekommen vielleicht hilft das gebet
einen schönen schluss des abenteuers zu
finden
dann betreten die scharf besitzer dem
pferch der jetzt zu arena wird die suche
nach den eigenen tieren das einfangen
der widerspenstigen daraus wird ein
alpines scharf rodeo wo irgendwie alle
griffe erlaubt sind
[Musik]
as rom zurück und gar nicht beworben
die kleinen eben welche haben sich
gefüllt
gespannt erwarten die scharf treiber nun
die abrechnung
[Musik]
hergekommen und wechseln zum zustand not
danach die
twitter
das glauben
[Applaus]
[Musik]
dass ich
sage nicht
eine letzte kleine geschichte als
nachtrag einige tage nach dem schaefer
fest fand eines der fünf verloren
geglaubten schafe alleine zurück auf die
bälle
walliser western können ganz schön
kitschig enden
[Musik]